why no no okay thank you sir
you stopped inevitable dude I don't
think I'll ever get tired of staring at
my own crack Oh twist up twisted I'm
beginning to think that this might not
actually be possible okay there goes my
front end so uh how y'all doing oh my
everything is backwards dinging I'm not
sure this is gonna help but baby that's
the prey damage
screw you miserable failure son sandy
wins this race how care what you have to
say I might be going into the mines
faster than I thought okay
well I'm screwed great
Wow
I kind of wonder if I'm able to take
this thing up there if I'm just dreaming
big okay well I would I wanted to go up
oh no no
again big fella gets you the blazing
speed oh wait where am I going
oh good lordy well there's my head what
happened to the rest of me don't mind I
don't think that's gonna be an issue
whoa wait no okay
does this look strange to you hey
whatever here we go no come back my
chicken seems to be dive-bombing quite a
bit flap your damn wings damn you flap
your damn damn wings come on
oh and death
all I gotta do is hit the pin no tricks
right you saw say [ __ ] there's no way
my bulldozer will be affected by the
okay then
this one's called marks heroic death I'm
not entirely sure what that means but
here we go okay well why yep topsy-turvy
still on it still with it still hittin
it still ready I'm good I'm good Ashley
alrighty then my legs backwards now I
guess that's a thing
I don't know if I should condone this
it's called the door to mine ville baby
my last ride goodbye oh wow all right
thank you all so much for watching
another episode of turbo dismount
there's much more turbo dismount in the
playlist in the description below or in
the annotation over there that was
really sad kid but thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video